[Music]
cara
is with us in sacramento california hi
kara how are you
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
um i am just
extremely overwhelmed i guess is the
best way to see it um i'm a single mom
i grew up also with a single mom and who
struggled i'm definitely not
as bad as off as i was growing up um
but i am still struggling and i i know
you're gonna say i have an income
problem i'm pretty sure
um i've my friend just introduced me to
you so i've been like
for the last few weeks listening to the
podcast and
you know like sometimes i'm like i got
that answer right i knew what you were
gonna say but i just can't handle my own
mess
for some reason um i just um
i filed bankruptcy in 2019 because a
creditor was going to take 25
of my wages um and at one point
i tried to put 10 in my retirement and i
didn't have enough for rent so
i knew 25 was like a no go so
i did file bankruptcy i did open a
couple credit cards after just to build
my credit
which now i know is a bad thing but um i
don't use them i
put a small amount i pay it right off i
was literally just trying to build my
credit i don't want a fiasco
um my rent is going up again in august
um
i just i don't know what to what to do
i'm terrified i have like how old
how old is your babies um well they're
actually
pretty much grown my youngest or my
oldest will be 24 in august and my
oldest
youngest will be 17 in august
and i'm 40. and you've raised them
completely by yourself
for the most part yeah um my youngest
one her dad
we he's basically raised both of them we
started getting my oldest one was five
months old so
he's her dad the only dad she knows but
um
yeah he's been in the picture the last
probably since she was
nine and been like continually in the
picture so
i know that you've been part you've been
an unmarried mother of children
yes their whole life and i yeah
yeah and i stopped them stop a man
stop a man okay you're a freaking hero
yeah you're amazing thank you
and you're exhausted i
am exhausted i mean i'm fortunate that
my job i'm a surgical technologist so
i'm
able to pick up extra shifts and call
and for many years i worked six or seven
days a week
and now don't you've not known how to do
anything for 20 years
except put out fires yeah
basically yeah and i've heard you twice
he gets tired
i've heard you twice on this call try to
try to minimize
what you're doing yeah but i'm really
lucky and yeah i know it could be worse
and yeah i know
you are doing hero work
and you've almost got it done i mean
you're almost done it was poorly amazing
okay so
so let's let's open the next chapter
let's open the next chapter and make it
awesome
together okay yes i'm so proud of my
girls every
now they are very financially conscious
and
to be as um of you as you are of your
girls
and you're not proud of your girls i'm
proud of you i'm proud of you
yes thank you all right so what do you
make of yours
um i my brain home is about
41. um it varies because and i just
recently started picking up
more shifts like a mad woman again but
yeah so what are you 45
44 yes oh pretty good guess almost like
i've done this
okay yeah time or two huh all right so
okay so you're a 45 year old uh single
lady whose kids are grown
yeah ha okay now yeah so for the next
20 years of your life 25 years of your
life
uh you get to have what we call an
encore
where you come out on the edge of the
stage after the play's over and you take
a bow and then you go again
so now now let's just start fresh let's
pretend we're 18
or we're 45 and we got a white board
where do you want to be
who do you want to be what do you want
to be doing when you're 65
um i want to not be afraid to retire
i'm talking about your career yeah oh my
career i i absolutely love my job i love
being a surgical tech i would love to go
and finish i would love for you to make
twice as much money as you make so what
are we going to do me too
nursing her pa has always been my goal
oh no
we're talking all right yeah i like that
one that's a good goal
so what are we going to take what steps
are we going to take to be a pa how are
we going to do this
um go back to school
and yeah go back to school and i i mean
i don't feel like
will the place you work for pay for it
um well they'll do tuition reimbursement
yeah that's kind of like paying for it
yeah
it's awesome yeah yeah i'm liking our
plan
already once you get to a certain point
you have to have
be able to support yourself and do it
because you can't work full-time anymore
with that
i know but listen you're already you're
already you're already setting up
roadblocks
and we're just going to pull them we can
do this for hours we keep pulling them
out so let me tell you what successful
people do
okay they look out there and they say
this is where i want to be
we've already identified that then we
ask ourselves the question
what has to be true for that to occur
that's not true today okay and we've
already established
some a couple of those things one is
you're going to go back to school two is
somehow you're gonna have to prepare
a way to eat while you have to take a
little bit of time off to finish that
schooling
and we're gonna get there and oh by the
way along the way we're gonna get out of
debt
and along the way we're and oh man
they're gonna pay for it for you so this
is getting even better
because there's tuition reimbursement
i'm loving this all along as a matter of
fact you might find a program that would
allow you to continue to work there
and do your do your practicum there uh
or whatever it is you're having to do i
don't know i haven't finished yet you
just started this is going to be awesome
awesome hey cara can i just talk to you
every day to cheer me up
hey kara listen i'm going to tell you
this in 30 seconds
okay my mom didn't go to college she
came from an ecosystem that didn't
invite
didn't support that at 42 she took her
first community college class
and then she took another one the next
year and another one the next year this
is my mom i watched it happen
and then at 53
she graduated no i'm sorry at 57 she
graduated with her phd
at 63 she was tenured and at 70. she
just stopped being the department chair
at the university that she now works at
so here's what i want you to that's a
map that dave's just telling you
honey you're just getting started you
have a home
i have the age who cares in my own head
it's in because you're talking to a 60
year old and i'm pissed off now
and listen dave's old trust me he's old
but he's still going
right just you're dead
when we get off there cara
you got a whole you got a you got the
back half to go you've just played nine
holes and you've got nine more to go
it's
encore baby take a bath i'm just feeling
like exhausted
hey you should be you should just
finished a freaking battle
of 18-year battle
a 20-year battle and you got battle
fatigue yeah and i i
am proud of the fact that i don't like
i'm not frivolous i mean i have my times
where i spend here and there that i
shouldn't if you haven't done some
stupid stuff you wouldn't be human
exactly yeah stop but i don't vacation
things like that okay so here's what
we're gonna do here's what we're gonna
do
okay you need to go through financial
peace university because you got this
stupid credit card stuff and this
bankruptcy stuff in your rear view
mirror
instead of out your windshield i'm tired
of it being in your windshield it needs
to be in the past yeah
and you put it back there we're going to
stop doing the stupid stuff that puts
you there
and that's the healing of your finances
are going to put you on track to go be a
pa
you're going to be a pa yes you are
and you're going to make more money from
55 to 70 than you did from 25 to 55.
and it's going to be so fun and
you're going to you're going to throw
your shoulders back and go look at me i
did do that's right
so you have taken care of everyone else
and now it's time to take care of you
you've been proud of everybody else and
now it's time to be proud of you
ding ding girl what a stud man
you're amazing hold on kelly's going to
pick up we're going to put you in a
ramsay plus membership for a year
as our as our gift to you to put you on
the way
and uh we want you to get in there and
get into financial peace university get
the every dollar app going
and get your get your finances
straightened out go to kencoleman.com
start following the stuff ken is doing
on career and
uh you have 30 days to start taking
solid steps
on this journey i don't want to talk to
you again
60 days from now and you have done
nothing except wine
you should go school this done be in
school get
going now